hey guys it's madison beer and this is
the wired auto complete interview
what a satisfying noise by the way so
let's get some asmr for the kids
i've watched every single one of these
videos and the fact that i'm holding a
board this is this is an honor we're
gonna begin
first question i can't believe i'm doing
this first question what is madison beer
i found this out the tough way there is
a beer company in wisconsin that is
called madison beer the reason that i
know this
is because i had to
pay them for their twitter handle online
my twitter handle used to be at madison
albeer which is my middle name they had
at madison beer
and i had to pay them a pretty penny
just kidding it wasn't that much money
but i but i did have to pay them and now
i know that there is a beer company in
madison wisconsin called madison beer
but madison beer is also
a little girl and she is me
what song is madison beer
known for
so this question i think would probably
be up for debate i would say selfish
probably did it for me i think that i
would i would like to say that's what
i'm known for it's my favorite song of
mine so i'm gonna say selfish i'm gonna
go with my single selfish and if you
haven't heard it go check it out next
question what is madison beer's vocal
range i've never been classified like a
soprano or an altar or anything like
that i've
i've kind of always sang
what is madison beer's fandom name i
should have seen this one coming this is
a topic of discussion amongst my fans so
when i was i think 13 or 14 i thought it
was genius to call my fans imaginers
i am a d
g i n e r s so like e mad
jenners
clearly a 13 year old made that up that
is not what my fandom is called i refuse
to call my fans imaginers they always
are like what what are we called and i i
don't know i don't know i think that
i'll let them pick it i'm more than
happy for their creative juices to flow
and they can come up with it i will
literally call you guys anything but
imagineers i just called them my friends
honestly they're like my homies and i
don't feel like i have necessarily a
fandom i feel like i've got a family not
to be too corny let's move on what
madison beer
tick tocks is that grammatically correct
am i reading that wrong what madison
beer tick tocks like what do i do on
tick tock i i cry sometimes i uh i'm
just kidding board number one
down the hatch
guys i can do this for hours i love this
next board this is so fun by the way who
is madison beer's best friend so i would
say that my best friend is this girl
named lena i met lena online she
to make a very like long-winded story
beautiful story short one of the best
things social media has ever brought to
me um she wrote this really compelling
and perceptive
basically like read on me and she just
basically posted something being like i
see her true colors and i know her heart
and i think that you know she just she
just saw me and i i don't feel seen a
lot by a lot of people and so i dm'd her
and i was like who are you i love you
you're so smart and so intuitive and
perceptive and i want to be friends with
you
and it's been almost two years since
she's been my best friend she's spent a
couple months with me in la and it's
been really beautiful so my best friend
her name is lena and she is my earth
angel and i love her more than anything
who is
tyler durden madison beer tyler jordan
is the character in fight club brad
pitt's character and fight club also
my favorite movie of all time i wrote a
song called tyler jordan and it was on
my debut ep as she pleases and it's
definitely my favorite off of the whole
ep so check that out but don't check it
out if you haven't seen the movie
because it's kind of a spoiler but watch
the movie why haven't you seen that
movie
okay
who did madison be your voice in monster
high okay this question this is a common
misconception i didn't voice anyone in
monster high sadly enough i sang a
version of a theme song years and years
and years ago
called we are monster high it was very
cool i got my own doll awesome
experience working with mattel like it
was really really cool but i didn't
voice anybody like i wish i was what's
her name frankie stein i wish i was one
of them i did not get to do that though
but i've also always wanted to be a
voice actor i can do a really mean rick
and morty impression which don't even
ask i'm not doing it but i can do one
and uh yeah i didn't get to voice anyone
though and i did but i did sing a theme
song
who madison beer outer banks
you're asking me you're asking the wrong
person i have no id i have no idea i'm
not in outer banks uh madeleine klein i
think is what you meant to write
but i'll take it i'll take the
compliment thank you for mistaking me
from madeleine klein
yay okay is madison beer a k-pop idol oh
um i don't i wouldn't consider myself a
k-pop idol but i did a k-pop song
feature with this group called kda for
league of legends which is a video game
we did this little girl group with
actually i did it with a k-pop band
called g-idle which they're amazing and
incredible so i guess i have made a
k-pop song but i wouldn't say i'm a
k-pop idol i'm going to give myself that
but it's definitely done very well and
people have taken a liking to it and i
actually got to perform in seoul in
south korea um like two or three years
ago and it was the most incredible
experience and i miss south korea a lot
it's such a beautiful place okay is
madison beer from long island you know
it baby what are you talking about of
course i'm from long island i grew up in
long island which isn't sorry if i'm
offending any long islanders but i'm a
long islander so i can say it it's not
as cool as manhattan it's just not so
whenever i tell people i'm from new york
i'm just hoping they just assume
manhattan they don't ask me but
i think the wolf of wall street kind of
put long island on a little bit and now
people like oh my god can you do the
marco robbie accent i'm like yeah i can
do the mario robby accent i can give you
her whole little spiel ready okay she
says well aren't you married
he says yep american people can't have
friends oh we're gonna be friends
we're not gonna be friends
there's my margot robbie wolf of wall
street impression everybody
but yeah i love being from long island i
love the accent maybe i should start the
rest of the video we're gonna talk like
this so let's keep it going
is madison beer left-handed i'm not
left-handed i'm right i'm right-handed
maybe i don't yeah no i'm not
left-handed okay is madison fear of
pisces
of course we're pisces i'm a pisces
wrestling gemini moon libra
scorpio mars
i keep going if you want me to read my
whole birth chart off i am a pisces i
actually wasn't always into astrology to
be completely honest with you i got into
it because literally no joke um i was at
a concert and i was walking down the
aisle and this woman literally came up
to me and was like you have the most
beautiful radiant pisces energy and i
was like in my head am i even a pisces
and i was like
how do you know that but i'm very very
very into astrology and i really believe
in it and i'm also like on a whole
spiritual journey and whatever so i am a
pisces proud to be one okay is madison
beer
in final destination is there a
character who looks like me in final
destination i am not in final
destination i've actually never seen it
because i remember hearing about a scene
in it when i was younger that was very
disturbing and i was like i don't want
to watch someone get their head cut off
on a roller coaster like no thank you
i'm not in final destination i've never
even seen it to be honest and
that's the end of board number three
let's keep going
now we got some houzz all right how was
madison beer discovered i was discovered
at 12 years old on youtube i was posting
um covers singing some songs and mr
justin bieber saw one of them and i was
signed to him and scooter and all that
stuff and it was a very it was a it was
a whirlwind you know i'm a random kid
from long island new york and
it doesn't happen so it was pretty
trippy that it happened to me it's been
literally 10 years since then and i will
always be eternally grateful to justin
for the initial kickstart and believing
in me you know at the beginning so it
was very cool it was very very very cool
for me how
to sing like madison beer oh
that's so sweet i wish i could tell you
i don't know honestly i would just
listen to as many covers or
songs of mine
as you can and if you want to copy it do
it it's nothing but a compliment to me
but also sing like you i want to hear
you sing sing your own version of my
song i love i love hearing people just
be themselves and um yeah so don't sing
like me sing like you how
uh how to hit madison beer riff okay so
i'm gonna assume this is referring to
the riff and selfish which went viral on
tick tock which was so cool because i
actually wish i had my phone on me i
could play you guys the
original version so when we initially
did the selfish riff it went down
which i couldn't even do it if i tried
because the high one is so implanted in
my brain but like it went down and i
remember listening to the demo and just
being like this doesn't feel
right i'm not into it and i tried so
many different
runs to go up and i couldn't nail it and
then literally like two days before we
sent it to master i was like let me try
one more thing and i accidentally did my
one that made it in the song and
it turned out people liked it and it was
so great just practice it's it's not
that hard to be honest it's probably
probably sounds harder than it is it's
fun it's not that many notes don't know
why i look there that way
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
it's not that many notes
you got it it's easy how to
be like madison beer why would you want
to be like me it's not what it shapes up
to be i promise
i promise you what you're seeing online
and what you think you know about me
what you think you know about anybody is
probably not even a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of what reality
is so don't get too hung up on that and
please remember that like you are seeing
what we and everyone wants you to see
don't get yourself in a comparison whole
of like looking at other people's lives
relationships looks you know success
you don't see what goes on behind the
scenes and i promise you there's a lot
of it so um just remember that you
you should be you
you don't need to be like me i promise
let's move on
all right this one's quick does madison
beer play lol oh i'm like what's low
league of legends i've tried it i'm
terrible at it does madison beer speak
spanish
was that even right i don't know i tried
to learn french in uh
quarantine
and i don't know how to say much but if
i'm trying to flirt with somebody i'll
say
foreign which means basically you'll
never understand how much i love you
does madison beer have tattoos she has
12 in fact they are predominantly and
a majority of them are on my feet that's
why you don't see them that's why i
don't know about them i really love this
one on my ring finger it says eventually
it's a it's a reference to the team
impala song eventually but i also just
think it has a
greater like meaning of just like things
will happen in time be patient don't
rush life you know let it happen i like
that one the best does madison here play
piano i do play piano i would not say
that i'm like a pianist or i'm good but
i do play piano i can get by pretty well
i can play all chords and yeah i love
piano it's it's the best does madison
beer have siblings i do i'm actually
repping him right now my little brother
ryder goes to the berkeley school of
music and he's amazing he wants to be
a producer and he has the most talent
and he's the cutest sweetest most
angelic and i love him so much he's
literally my world so i do my baby
brother ryder yeah ryder and i haven't
fully done a collab yet but we're
planning on it we're gonna you know he's
he's got some work to do but we're gonna
we're gonna do it together we're gonna
do it final board i'm sad
why why why madison beer i'm gonna
assume that's a reference to my song
dead
why why why why why why why
that's my song dead when i say that i
say the word why i actually would love
to do a y count of how many times i say
it i'm not sure at the top of my head
but i do say it a lot yyy madison beer i
ask myself the same thing every day it's
definitely one of my like core songs i
would say um it is a landmark song for
me
it was my first song as an independent
artist it was like a really just a
special song i actually also just really
love the messaging behind it because i
feel like now also that i'm older i like
have understood the messaging a little
bit more which is like if you say you
can't live without me why aren't you
dead yet it basically is just like you
know keeping somebody accountable for
their word and that's that's kind of the
premise of the song obviously not
literally don't take it literal madison
beer olivia rodrigo i don't know if this
is a question or a statement but um i
love olivia rodrigo i think she's so
talented i think her music is incredible
and she's so pretty and cute and sweet
seeming i don't know her but she seems
adorable so madison beer olivia rodrigo
question mark
olivia
hit a girl up but um yeah she's amazing
and i'm really really proud of her and
all her success i'm like blown away by
everything she releases proud to be
grouped in with someone like her where
does madison beer get her hoops i really
am not like a i need to wear expensive
hoops to be fair i can't wear fake
jewelry my ears will literally like turn
green and i have like genuine allergic
reactions to fake jewelry so i do get at
least like gold-plated jewelry but i
this it doesn't run you up too much
um where is madison beer right now right
now i am in my home in long island new
york very happy to be here
all right zero
are you ready for your debut
i can't he's the cutest thing look at
this size of this thing
hi baby i know you're wet why are you
wet were you running around somewhere
nothing really came as a surprise to me
these were all great questions and i'm
i'm very happy with how it turned out
all right wired thank you so much for
having me this was a dream come true
i've literally wanted to do one of these
my entire life so thank you so much
thanks say thank you zero we'll see you
guys soon love you